hey guys in this video I'm going to
introduce you with the new official
teaser for season 7 that has been
released yesterday along with my
detailed explanation yesterday was a
huge day for Game of Thrones fans the
most exciting days to the season 6
wrapped up yesterday Israel firstly
announced that during a Facebook white
stream that they are going to reveal the
premiere date of Game of Thrones 7
season and later that day brought us and
interactive facebook event in which fans
were brought in to live feed of ice and
fire team teaser poster that was brought
to life a flame towers that were
portraying the dragon fire were powered
by the strength of thousands of fans
that we're watching this live stream by
typing fire or dracarys in chat were
able to speed up the process along with
a few main game of thrones factors and
actresses that we're encouraging us
along with support of Isaac
hempstead-wright Lena Headey Grandal
increased she Alfie Allen Nikolaj
coster-waldau and liam Cunningham the
block of ice after not that short amount
of time finally melted down and revealed
a data premiere of the first episode of
the seventh season which will premiere
on July sixteenth like this wasn't
exciting enough Game of Thrones released
on its official Twitter account shortly
after the season 7 premiere date was
revealed released a teaser for the
forthcoming season these are dead they
have also shared on their official
YouTube channel they didn't release any
type of trailer as many of us surely
thought at first they release another
teaser for the upcoming season but this
one is very more exciting than any
previous released one there's a link in
description of that official teaser in
case you can watch it I recommend you to
watch it first and then come to hear my
explanation as we can see this clip
doesn't include new scenes this preview
that doesn't physically show any
character as this isn't a trailer but a
teaser that includes a series of quotes
from various factions as their family
jewels float across the screen includes
the most noted lines of the main
characters other throughout the series
accompanied with different house sigils
rendered in stone stoned it crumbles
towards the end while most of the lives
are already within the show the last one
is a brand new line that we are going to
hear
season 7 jon snow's line there's only
one more that matters the Great War and
it is here these are starts the
three-headed dragon Targaryen sigil as
the nares the discussion over her father
takes place discussion over the Mad King
that she has got Victorian eda episode
of its season which in my opinion is
reminding us that the nearest one just
come with her three dragons and burned
the whole King's Landing down in order
to conquer the Iron Throne and she is
not going to be the mad Queen she won't
burn the whole city along with all
innocent people in it in order to
conquer and to bring her house back
Darren thrown that has been taken from
them since she only intends to kill a
queen and her allies along with their
armies then we can hear Roberts line
from a conversation that he had with Ned
Stark in the second episode of the very
first season line in which King Robert
while to kill every Targaryen which is
only reminding us that one of them was
in front of Robert was raised and
protected by Roberts best friend Ned
Stark proclaimed john is a bastard son
of heads in order to keep his promise
that he gave to his dying sister in
order to protect her son whose father is
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen as these are
continuously can hear search his line
this year for the Joffrey in the third
episode of the first season we can hear
Cersei statement in which she revealed
that everyone who isn't one of them one
of her family is enemy and as we are
hearing that line we can also see a lion
lannister schedule attacking stag
brought in sigil reminding us that
Cersei is guilty for Robert stat which
is probably also some kind of reminder
that Cersei is capable to do much more
damaging she is brewing that Cersei one
that is will give up on her throne and
give it to the nearest as soon as they
arrive at westroads with her huge army
sent with her three large dragons other
than those three lines there's also
Joffrey's order to execute that Stark
Balon Greyjoy's line about him and his
children being Ironborn along with the
statement that they take what is theirs
which is reminding us that Theon and his
sister Yara are Ironborn that they are
going to try to take what should be
theirs which is on confirming even more
already confirmed event that we are
going to see in the first episode of
season
seven a fleet battle image balans
children supported with Danny's Li the
sand snakes will try to take from your
own Greyjoy the Iron Islands something
that should be theirs we can also hear
roses most popular line the Lannisters
send their regards which is proving once
again that the Lannisters are capable to
pull out something big even in the
situation in which it seemed that they
are doomed it seems that this teaser is
really trying to convince us that Cersei
won't be defeated anytime soon as in the
next line we can here Lady Olenna
confession about poisoning Joffrey that
she revealed to her granddaughter
Marjorie while at the same time we can
also see torn strapping a lion as the
queen of thorns kill King Joffrey only
to a few seconds later here chi burns
proclamation of Cersei being a new queen
and ruler of Seven Kingdoms as you can
also see Terrelle sigil arose being
destroyed by wildfire reminding us that
Cersei destroyed house Tyrell by killing
mace Loras and Marjorie living Elena as
the sole survivor of house Tyrell
leaving house Tyrell to die out in the
near future just before the end the
stone house sigil models that are
revealed to be entertained start
collapsing as the nearest speech about
the wheel of changing rollers she
intends to break is taking place as a
narrative speech is over as all how
schedules are crushed we can hear Jon
Snow's line that will take place in one
of the season seven scenes John speech
in which he is revealing that the Great
War is the only word that matters and it
is here speech that in my opinion will
take place in Dragonstone speech image
on snow no try to convince Daenerys that
the Iron Throne doesn't matter that the
war between a few Great Houses doesn't
matter we'll try to convince Daenerys to
lead her armies and her large dragons to
the north because the great for is not
coming anymore it's here as Jon Snow is
talking about Great War came as zoom
south to reveal the rabble forming the
spiral associated with White Walkers
before the shot settles on the pale blue
eye of someone or something that it
first looks like an eye of white Walker
but if you watch it a few times it looks
more like dragons than the White Walkers
I which might be an official
confirmation that one of the nurses
dragons as lakes plus says they'll be
killed and reanimated by the night King
this rancid data premiere of the first
episode of the seventh season kit
harington an actor that plays chance now
increased our excitement about new
season with his interview that he had
this huffington post harrington replies
on a question about whether or not
season seven deserves the hype it's been
getting with yes I'm gonna say yes I
mean I hope it is I certainly did more
this season than I've ever done I think
every actor on it did more action had
more action had more scenes it means
that we are going to see much more in
this short upcoming season that we are
going to see much more exciting scenes
in only seven episodes then we could see
in previous seasons that had been
episodes meaning that every single
episode will be more than interesting
other than this is very exciting teaser
in this video you will also be
introduced to the huge information that
has been leaked a few days ago utter the
Academy award-winning actor Jim
Broadbent confirmed himself that he will
appear in the upcoming season we didn't
know anything about his role while we
could have assumed that he will portray
archmaester eyebrows as Broadbent will
be the best actor to portray already
mentioned character the mystery of
broadband troll was revealed a few days
ago as the actor himself has confirmed
in the interview with screencrush his
role in season 7 has confirmed that
he'll play in archmaester in Game of
Thrones broadband sad I'm a master and
archmaester I'm an El profesor character
beside his confirmation she has also
confirmed his appearance in five
episodes along with him appearing in one
major scene of each of those five
episodes he said I did sort of one major
scene in each episode now that we know
that Jim Broadbent is going to play
eyebrows let's see what we know about
that character eyebrows is the arch
maester of the Citadel kutas analysis
shaking their link in the art of healing
his ring mask and rod are made up of
silver his kind and soft-spoken let me
also how I brought that statement that
his scenes were shared with John Bradley
an actor that plays similarly a
confirmation about those two sharing
scenes with leaked photos that are
confirming jores grayscale being cured
and with the side that broadband
character is the healing master
I came to conclusion that salmon
dubrow's will find a cure for jurors
grayscale will heal jores disease there
has also been announced that mask
gunslinger nos in the guard will appear
as an extra in the upcoming season of
Game of Thrones in interview about his
appearance in the guard only revealed
I'm clothing to just know that I'm a fan
and they invited me to do that I
couldn't say no while syndergaard gave
very few details from his appearance we
managed to find out that he films his
appearance in Spain back in November and
as always feel free to share your
thoughts about this video in the comment
section down below let me know your
opinion about the whole teaser
especially about who's I do you think
it's in the very end also let me know
your thoughts on new confirmation about
roll the gym broadband is going to play
hope you guys enjoyed the video if it is
please make sure to subscribe to our
channel and I hope to see in the next
piece
[Music]
you